[Musique]
le soleil se lève sur les remparts du
plus haut sommet de la reine y culminant
à 3071 m le piton des neiges est au
coeur du patrimoine naturel de notre île
chaque année des milliers de randonneurs
se lance dans son ascension et sur leur
route un point d'étape incontournable
son refuge propriétaire du site le
département lance une série de travaux
de réhabilitation sur ce gîte qui
fonctionne de manière autonome en
commençant par l'évacuation des déchets
d'assainissement
lorsqu'on va faire c'est que du 26 juin
au 13 juillet une entreprise a été
missionné pour évacuer les j les déchets
assainissement et les fosses septiques
donc et les contenants par hélicoptère
savoir que l'endroit où sont situés les
phoques est vraiment à l'écart du refuge
donc on n'aura peur on aura les gîtes
heures et les randonneurs n'ont pas de
gêne que ce soit visuel ce un petit peu
sonore avec les hélicos rotation délits
commis dans l'ensemble ce sera mieux
pour toi
avec dix-sept mille nuitées chaque année
ce refuge et le plus fréquentée par les
randonneurs à la réunion les
départements souhaitent valoriser cet
espace et en faire un hébergement de
qualité
il faut savoir que le département initié
un grand programme de rénovation de ses
onze gîtes dont le gîte du piton des
neiges qui en fait partie
il ya des travaux conservatoires qui
interviendront cours en 2018 qui
consisteront essentiellement à
réhabiliter les menuiseries les réseaux
électriques permettent d pose de bardage
en fibrociment aux alentours du site
pour pouvoir faire en sorte et bien que
le gîte heures puisse avoir un point
d'étape sur un site valorisé comme celui
ci ce sont pas loin je dois le rappeler
chaque parloir 55000 randonneurs qui
passent tous les ans sur ce site et il
nous faut pour sa part la volonté du
conseil départemental assurer à la fois
confort sur un site comme celui ci pour
que et bien le plaisir soit également
associé au confort du séjour les
améliorations du gîte se finaliseront
d'ici cinq ans avec un projet ambitieux
de reconstruction complète de ce refuge
situé dans un paysage unique inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
[Musique]